eine mikrowelle hat ja fast jeder zu
hause aber kann man diesem teil traum
mikrowellen kost macht schwach massive
zerstörung gesunder nährstoffe
verstrahltes und totes essen und auch in
foren wird es immer wieder diskutiert
typischer fall vom das werden wir nie
herausfinden
nein genau das werden wir herausfinden
und zwar jetzt
[Musik]
ok freunde der sonne um zu verstehen was
die mikrowelle mit unserem essen
anstellt wissen wir zuerst verstehen was
mikrowellen überhaupt sind mikrowellen
sind elektromagnetische strahlung wir
werden ständig von elektromagnetischer
strahlung bestrahlt zum beispiel durch
die sonne
wenn ihr mein video über farben gesehen
hat dann wisst ihr licht ist
elektromagnetische strahlung die gibt es
in allen möglichen wellenlängen
röntgenstrahlen radiowellen uv-strahlen
lasst uns das hier ein bisschen
vertiefen denn wellenlänge ist eine sehr
wichtige eigenschaft von strahlung also
was heißt wellenlänge
das hier ist eine große will länge und
das hier ist eine kleine welt denke man
kann auch sagen das hier ist eine
niedrige frequenz und das hier ist eine
hohe frequenz wenn wir farben sehen ist
es nichts anderes als elektromagnetische
strahlung die auf unsere netzhaut fällt
dabei ist rotes licht länger wellig laus
nicht kürzer will dich dieses sichtbare
licht hat einen wellenlängenbereich von
ein paar hundert nanometern
doch das elektromagnetische spektrum ist
noch viel breiter es gibt allen dingen
in pico meter bereich und wellenlängen
im meter bis kilometer bereich und es
gilt je kürzer die wellenlänge oder je
höher die frequenz desto energiereicher
ist die strahlung energiereich kann
problematisch sein am kurzwelligen ende
des spektrums haben wir zum beispiel
röntgenstrahlung mit wellenlängen von
unter zehn nanometer röntgenquellen sind
so energiereich dass sie zum beispiel
elektronen aus atomen herausschlagen
können zu gehören zur sogenannten
ionisierenden strahlung
können zellen und dna schädigen auch die
etwas länger wellige uv-strahlung gehört
noch zur juni zierenden strahlung
weswegen zu viel sonne auch nicht gesund
ist
wisst ihr ja ab den wellenlängenbereich
des sichtbaren lichts also ab 400
nanometern ist elektromagnetische
strahlung nicht mehr ionisierend kann
also auch keine molekularen schäden
hervorrufen mikrowellen sind auch nicht
ionisierend der mikrowellen herd in der
küche arbeitet mit strahlung im
wellenlängenbereich von ungefähr zwölf
zentimeter also deutlich länger weil ich
als sichtbares licht und damit auch
deutlich energie ärmer aber wellenlänge
und frequenz sind nicht alles es gibt
auch noch die amplitude eine welle kann
bei gleicher wellenlänge und frequenz
unterschiedlich hohe amplituden haben je
höher die amplitude desto intensiver ist
die strahlung intensität ist
physikalisch gesprochen leistung oder
power pro fläche wie viel power sohn
mikrowellenherd hat das verraten uns die
wattzahl beziehungsweise auf den neuen
mikrowellen steht ja auch nicht mehr was
drauf sondern irgendwelche komischen
fisch fleisch kartoffeln das macht alles
nur komplizierter schweife ab
mikrowellen herde operieren bei
leistungen von 150 bis 900 watt damit
kann man essen erwärmen wlan-router
allerdings die auch mikrowellen
ausstrahlen und zwar in einer ganz
ähnlichen frequenz 2,4 gigahertz sind
auf 0,1 watt beschränkt also rund 1000
bis 10.000 fach schwächer deshalb kann
man auf einem wlan router trotz
passender frequenz keine essensreste
aufwärmen doch warum wird essen in der
mikrowelle überhaupt heiß wie
mikrowellen herde funktionieren nehmen
wir mal ein wassermolekül h2o das ort
umzieht stärker elektronen zu sich so
entsteht am atom ein negativer ladung
überschuss ade nato ein positiver
ladungs überschuss man sagt auch das h2o
molekül ist cola in einem elektrischen
feld orientieren sich die polaren
wassermolekül
der ladung entsprechend
elektromagnetische wellen wirken auch
wie elektrische felder nur das plus und
minus ständig wechseln man sagt das feld
oszilliert mikrowellen sind jetzt genau
in der richtigen größenordnung um mit
wassermolekülen zu interagieren durch
das oszillieren das hält richten sich
die wassermoleküle ganz schnell
abwechselnd aus und fand an sich zu
drehen durch das drehen und auch durch
das aneinanderreihen von molekülen
entsteht hitze
das ganze funktioniert auch mit anderen
polaren molekülen wie zb zucker oder
fette nur nicht ganz so gut wie mit dem
wasser denn fettmoleküle sind lange
moleküle die nicht so klein und
beweglich sind wie wassermoleküle
übrigens ist temperatur nichts anderes
als die bewegung von molekülen das heißt
auch wenn ich essen in einem topf
erhitzen bringe ich meine essens
moleküle dazu sich schneller zu bewegen
also was heißt das jetzt für
behauptungen wie mikrowellen verstrahlen
das essen mikrowellen sind nicht
ionisierende strahlung die ist
physikalisch gar nicht dazu in der lage
atom oder molekül zu verändern und
dadurch zellen oder dna zu schädigen
das kann nur ionisierende strahlung wie
gamma wintgen und uv strahlung
stattdessen bringt mikrowellen einfach
nur die moleküle zum drehen dabei
entsteht hitze und dabei passiert auch
nicht viel anderes als bei anderen arten
der die befürchtung das essen zu
verstrahlen muss man also nicht haben
und übrigens dieses ding hier ist kein
strahlenschutz sondern einfach nur ein
spritzschutz wenn plastik vor
mikrowellen schützen würde
dann wird sich ja auch dass es nicht
erwerben okay aber warum wird auf
babynahrung so oft von mikrowellen
gewarnt hier kommen wir zu einem klaren
nachteil von mikrowellen mikrowellen
erhitzen ungleichmäßig das liegt vor
allem an dem aufbau von mikrowellen
wenn ihr in euren mikrowellenherd
reinschaut dann seht ihr dass das teil
mit metall ausgekleidet ist aber lofer
eine mikrowelle zum großen teil aus
metall besteht solltet ihr keinen mit
halt in die mikrowelle reintun bis dir
bestimmt vor allem vergitterte alufolie
oder spitze ecken wie bei gabeln können
zu funken überhitzung und zerstörung der
mikrowelle führen dass nun als kleiner
sicherheits einschub zurück zur frage
warum die metallwände dazu führen dass
das essen ungleichmäßig jetzt wird die
metallwände reflektieren die mikrowellen
auch die tür reflektiert sie ist mit
einem metallgitter versehen die löcher
sind deutlich kleiner als die
wellenlänge der mikrowellen sichtbares
licht kommt dadurch deswegen wir auch
sehen können was in der mikrowelle los
ist aber auf die langweiligen
mikrowellen gibt das gitter wie eine
geschlossene metallband genau wie ich
zum beispiel nicht in und moden gitter
reinfall solange die gitter löcher
kleiner sind als meine füße durch diesen
faradayschen käfig so nennt man das
bleiben die mikrowellen im inneren der
kiste was ihr auch schönes weil wir
draußen ja nicht mitgekocht werden
wollen die mikrowellen werden also im
inneren reflektiert und überlagern sich
und dabei entstehen stehende wellen
stehende wellen kann man auch mit einem
normalen seil herstellen da gibt es ganz
schön youtube-videos und da seht ihr
stehende wellen haben fixe knotenpunkte
und maximal punkte in der mikrowelle
sieht es dann so aus an den
knotenpunkten haben wir kalte stellen an
denen maximal punkten heiße stellen wir
haben keine ebenmäßige erhitze deshalb
auch die drehscheibe und hinzu kommt ja
noch das wasser zwar sehr gut erhitzt
wird aber fällt zum beispiel weniger gut
oder auch das führt zu ungleichmäßiger
temperaturverteilung plastiki ist wenn
ich essen in der mikrowelle wahr mache
dann ist das essen nicht einfach außen
am heißesten wie bei dem ofen sondern es
ist eine totale surprise wo ich mir da
drin meine zunge verbrennen
deswegen auch vorsicht bei babynahrung
doch neben der überhitzung gibt es noch
ein problem mit mikrowellen und zwar
bakterien und keime sterben erst ab
einer gewissen temperatur
da wir in der mikrowelle überall kalte
flecken
da wo die knotenpunkte sind werden dann
natürlich auch keine bakterien abgetötet
deswegen sollte man in mikrowellen auch
kein rohes fleisch kochen
mal ganz abgesehen vom geschmack doch
auch wenn normal gekochtes essen immer
wieder in der mikrowelle aufgewärmt wird
steigt das risiko für eine
verunreinigung durch keine deshalb beim
wieder aufhören mit der mikrowelle immer
wieder zwischendrin umrühren und darauf
achten dass wirklich alles heiß wird das
heißt mikrowellen sind nicht zu
empfehlen wenn man etwas richtig
ordentlich durch kochen möchte und auch
nicht wenn man etwas sehr schonend nur
erwärmen möchte einfach war man über die
temperatur keine besonders gute
kontrolle hat bleibt nur noch die letzte
frage zerstören mikrowellen die
wertvollen nährstoffe in lebensmitteln
wie gesagt molekulare veränderung durch
strahlung ist bei mikrowellen nicht drin
aber natürlich verändert erhitzen
so manche chemische struktur ich meinen
kochen ist halt auch nur chemie ob
vitamine antioxidantien und co durch
erhitzen kaputt gehen dazu gibt es ein
altes schön schlau video von uns schaut
euch das gerne an aber die kurze antwort
ist es kommt aus lebensmittel an
manche sachen wie vitamin c zum beispiel
gehen bei hitze tatsächlich kaputt
andere wertvolle nährstoffe sind durch
hitze leichter zugänglich weil dadurch
zum beispiel schwer verdauliche
cellulosefasern zersetzt werden wenn man
jetzt gemüse in der mikrowelle
zubereitet dann hat man bei
ungleichmäßiger hitze natürlich auch
beide effekte gleichzeitig doch meistens
wird man in der mikrowelle ja sowieso
nur bereits gekochtes essen auf das gilt
auch für die meisten fertig mikrowellen
gerichte es gibt sogar einige studien
aus der lebensmittelchemie die
verschiedene arten des erhitzen
untersucht haben für linke ich aber da
gibt es auch keinen hinweis darauf dass
mikrowellen zubereitung generell
schlechter für nährstoffe ist die
lustigste studie zumindest für die
freunde der sonne die diesen kanal schon
länger schauen ist diese studie über t
grüner tee enthält moleküle namens
katechinen die eine reihe
gesundheitsförderlichen eigenschaften
haben sollen und die man durch das
brünen heißem wasser extrahiert immer
jetzt aus dem grünen tee maximal tick
hat die schiene rausholen möchte
empfehlen die forscher eine halbe minute
ziehen in kochendem wasser gefolgt von
einer einminütigen mikrowellen
behandlung so gemerkt schmeckt das ganze
aber nicht so gut weil catherine
ziemlich bitter sind insofern danke für
die info damals sind hoffentlich die
wichtigsten fragen zur mikrowelle messen
geklärt und ich kann jetzt endlich über
die heutigen mikrowellen renten jetzt
mal ganz im ernst jemand der diesen
ganzen zirkus hier besser findet ist
einfach nur zwei mädchen mit bart und
zeit jetzt was sollen diese automatische
programme sie dreist was mache ich jetzt
wenn die reise auf werden will hier kann
man angeblich die leistung anstellen das
habe ich bis heute noch nicht
herausgefunden wo man steht